[Music]
jordan starts us off in pittsburgh hey
jordan welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi yeah thank you so much for having me
on sure how can we help
yeah i'm just going to jump right into a
little story and ask a question
concerning that story so recently my
wife and i
we actually suffered a miscarriage of
our
twin babies around 14 weeks pregnant
um currently yeah currently we have
um oh thank you um
currently we have a two-year-old at home
as well as a dog
and my wife she actually
wants another puppy golden retriever
and her birthday is coming up soon
i'm finding it hard to say no because in
a wake of all the grief and sorrow
my concern would be the cost because she
is a vet tech and
trained our dog really well um she
recently took a course through the
church of jesus christ of latter-day
saints a financial course and
i listen to your shows i drive for uber
so we both understand the importance of
eliminating debt as soon as possible
so my question is um you know i love my
wife very much and find it extremely
hard to say no
to a dog after all that has happened
especially on her birthday
but financially speaking how does
someone appropriately respond
uh in wake of a devastating event like a
miscarriage
i think there's two approaches to that
i've i've
um sat in your exact seat
and in all honesty full disclosure i
handled it pretty poorly
and so i'm gonna speak to you from
somebody who did that the wrong way
um and then i'd love to hear what you
have to say dave i i
i think first and foremost you've got to
recognize in a
real immediate right now kind of way and
in a deep and profound way that y'all
two
are going to grieve this differently
and there's not a right and wrong way to
grieve it there's just a wrong way to
approach it which is
that you and or her but usually it's the
guy
decides that his way of grieving is best
and so it's time to move on and let's
get there let's get there
quickly and so honoring her and her
grief system number two
you're gonna need to she's gonna need to
get somebody in her life that is a
mentor of some shape form or fashion
um that kid has been there that can
listen that can talk with her
and not let her be alone in this
situation
i think telling somebody well my
recommendation is always nobody
making any long-term decisions like
buying a dog or buying a car buying a
house for six months to a year
after you have some sort of loss that
was the advice i got from my counselor
at the time and that's the advice i've
continued to
give to folks over the years i know that
can be hard as a husband
that's usually a conversation that
somebody's that's usually a response
that somebody's feeling disconnected
and so what i'd recommend you to do is
go find somebody you can talk to
together
and talk about loss and loneliness and
sometimes that takes the air out of the
need to go
spend go by go replace that's just a
grieving moment that is
all messed up in disconnection um
have you sat down and talked to somebody
with her have y'all talked to somebody
um we both have a really strong support
system but we haven't talked to like
somebody specifically
together we've talked about it a lot and
then since she's been to counseling
that's kind of one of the things here in
pittsburgh that they did for her
um on one of her follow-up appointments
they got hooked up with a counselor
so i recommend you all go together and
have somebody have a neutral third party
that's sitting there with you that you
can talk about
what does coping behavior look like and
what does tomorrow look like
and what does trying to punt the pain
down the road which is what buying a dog
is
um and really give you all some
strategies and tools right now to sit in
it together
so you're hearing loud and clear jordan
that not buying the dog
is not about money
right it's about it's about it's a
it's a coping mechanism and it allows
you to
not deal with what you need to go deal
with is what dr john's saying
okay so the two of you sit down with
somebody and
um you should make a decision to
do long-term things like buy a dog
like children like
[Music]
buying a house or a big investment or
something from a point of emotional
health and strength and when you guys
have been when anyone anyone's been
through what you guys have been through
you're not at you're not strong right
now and just say that out loud
and say because i'm not strong i'm not
making big decisions right now
and if you can get her to say that with
you then the
dog thing goes away but it's not because
dave ramsey said no you need to get out
of debt not by a dog
um you know your feelings be damned i
mean that's not that's
not the discussion you're that we're
having here and so
uh although i will tell you that
possibly the best dog on the planet
is the golden retriever i'm going to
strongly disagree i like the basset
hound but
but and i think it's also important for
guys out there to
say out loud um basset hound
i love me a basset hound man i love
basset hound it took me a minute to get
that one
i couldn't even get the picture they
just looked like god had some
miscellaneous parts left over
and he stuck him together and was like
let this let's let this one go
um yeah they're the most stubborn
obnoxious
i told you the lovely dogs is loving and
kind
yeah i don't need we don't need that
kind of love i need some big eyes
and just loves you when you when you're
you know it's the right kind of dog
no i just you probably said
bastard hounds man you never saw it
coming i never saw that one coming
get one dave i would have guessed pug or
something but i would have seen
fascinating